oh
honestly whoever's doing the music today
that is a perfect song for this story as
we welcome you back spot on as Nate says
to CBS mornings who are you who
we are getting a revealing new look at
Congressman George Santos who lied about
much of his life story before his
successful election in the house in
November he's also accused of fraud as
well as making up a story about his
mother's 9 11 experience Republican
leaders on Capitol Hill are still
standing behind Mr Santos while
Democrats and GOP officials in his home
districts are saying he's got to go
they're demanding his resignation now a
former friend and a roommate who knew
Santos under another name is telling his
story to CBS Caitlin Huey Burns has been
all over this case she's got the new
details Caitlin good morning to you I'm
afraid to ask what do we know
good morning Gail well Moore is coming
out by the day and we spoke to the
roommate his name is Gregory Moore he
says he lived with Santos back in early
2010s and he said he initially bonded
with him but then quickly discovered
there was much more to his story
George Santos is whoever you want him to
be at whatever time you want him to be
just that simple I called him the Anna
delvey of Queens Gregory Mori says he
first met the future New York
Congressman nearly a decade ago he never
went by George never went by Santos I
knew him as you know Anthony devalder
from Jackson Heights Queens Maury
befriended the outgoing young man even
moving in with him for a few months in
New York City he was
a very interesting person we hit it off
right away he says Santos told him he
had his sights set on Congress he told
me once that if I can get elected to
congress for just one term I will be set
with a pension in health care for the
rest of my life and when he heard his
former roommate actually achieved that
goal he was stunned I was like you gotta
be no no no this can't be no no no
George no no no no no that just blew my
brain I was just it's like that emoji on
your iPhone you know like the
Santos's family friend who says she
lived with him sporadically in Brazil
and in the U.S claimed Santos stole from
her she told CBS news from her home in
Brazil that she no longer recognizes the
boy she once knew
she says Santos has become someone who
will do anything to stay in power and
Santos shows no signs of stepping down
look I've worked my entire life I've
lived an honest life I've never been a
accused suit of any bad doing this week
he secured spots on two committees and
has the backing of House GOP leadership
meanwhile extraordinary stories about
Santos continue to surface I knew I was
being scammed disabled veteran Rich
osthoff says in 2016 Santos helped him
raise three thousand dollars for his
sixth service dog through Santos's pet
charity but ostov says he never got the
money from Santos with whom he says he
had allegedly exchanged these text
messages his dog died six months later
it diminished my faith in humanity and
there's this apparent falsehood on his
campaign website Santos claimed his
mother was working in the World Trade
Center on 9 11. yet a federal source
told CBS News her immigration documents
show she was in Brazil at the time of
the attack Noah bookbinder is the
president of citizens for responsibility
and ethics in Washington in any other
profession can you imagine someone like
George Santos being allowed to keep his
job absolutely not for a whole lot less
dishonesty they would be driven out of
their positions and and nobody would
feel bad about that
now Santos has denied these allegations
made by that veteran regarding the pet
scam but he hasn't yet responded to
these claims about his mother being in
the towers at 9 11. and guys he's been
actually pretty difficult to track we
called his he has no public events and
we actually called his district office
yesterday and we were forwarded to that
of a neighboring freshman Congressman
Tony hmm that is remarkable as is so
much else in that report Caitlin thank
you very much uh I was all over this
story I mean but the more you hear guys
the more jaw-dropping it becomes and I
love the Republican supporters who are
standing by him saying well the people
elected him it's up for the people who
decide but they elected him not knowing
this information that's what makes a
difference yes politicians always you
know provide certain facts about their
background for a certain image but this
is making up things whole cloth I mean
the list of Whoppers is very long I will
say there's one bit of good news I
looked up a one-term member of Congress
is not actually going to get a pension
okay life that is not going to happen he
would have to be re-elected twice six
years is the basic uh so let's see if he
gets reelected I mean right right it's
not out of the question no there's
another story that he was wearing a
Burberry scarf that he had taken from a
roommate roommate at the stop the steel
uh stop the steel rally the more you
hear the worse it gets and I'm surprised
that he has any supporters because he's
behaving in ways we all teach our
children not to do it
yeah people don't take that pretty
seriously around here more